right now you know the average you know
art history student or something
probably isn't going to you know they're
not probably they don't think they know
about programming and things like this
but by the time it really becomes a kind
of purely you know you just walk up to
it there's no documentation you start
just typing you know compare these
pictures with these pictures and you
know see the use of this color whatever
and you generate this piece of of
computational language code that gets
run you see the results you say oh that
looks roughly right or you say that's
crazy
um and maybe then you eventually get to
say well I better actually try and
understand what this computational
language code did
um and and that becomes the thing that
you learn just like it's kind of an
interesting thing because unlike with
mathematics where you kind of have to
learn it before you can use it this is a
case where you can use it before you
have to learn it well I got a sad
possibility here or maybe exciting
possibility that very quickly people
won't even look at the a computational
language they'll trust that it's
generated correctly as you get better
and better generating that language uh
yes I think that there will be enough
cases where people see you know because
you can make it generate tests too yes
and and so you'll say
um we're doing that I mean that's it's a
pretty cool thing actually yes because
you you know say this is the code and
you know here are a bunch of examples of
running the code yeah okay people will
at least look at those and they'll say
that example is wrong and you know then
it'll kind of wind back from there and I
agree that that the the kind of the
intermediate level of people reading the
computational language code in some case
people will do that in other case people
just look at the tests
and or even just look at the results and
sometimes it'll be obvious that you got
the thing you wanted to get because you
were just describing you know make me
this interface that has two sliders here
and you can see it has that those two
sliders there and that's that's kind of
that's that's the result you want but I
I think you know one of the questions
then is in that setting where you know
you have this kind of ability broad
ability of people to access computation
what should people learn you know in
other words right now you you know you
go to Computer Science school so to
speak and a large part of what people
end up learning I mean it's been a funny
historical development because back you
know 30 40 years ago computer science
departments were quite small and they
taught you know things like final
automata Theory and compiler Theory and
things like this
um you know company like mine rarely
hired people who'd come out of those
programs because the stuff they knew was
I think it's very interesting I love
that theoretical stuff but um you know
it wasn't that useful for the things we
actually had to build build in software
engineering and then kind of there was
this big pivot in the in the 90s I guess
where there was a big demand for sort of
I.T type programming and so on and
software engineering and then you know
big demand from students and so on you
know we want to learn this stuff and uh
and and I think you know the thing that
really was happening in part was lots of
different fields of human endeavor were
becoming computational you know for all
acts there was a there was a
computational x and this is a um uh and
that was the thing that um that people
were responding to
um and but then kind of this idea
emerged that to get to that point the
main thing you had to do was to learn
this kind of trade or or skill of doing
you know programming language type
programming and and that uh you know it
kind of is a strange thing actually
because I you know I remember back when
I used to be in the professor in
business which is now 35 years ago so
gosh that's rather long time
yeah
um you know it was it was right when
they were just starting to emerge kind
of computer science departments that
sort of a fancy research universities
and so on I mean some had already had it
but the the other ones that that um were
just starting to have that and it was
kind of a a thing where they were kind
of wondering are we going to put this
thing that is essentially a a trade-like
skill are we going to somehow attach
this to the rest of what we're doing and
a lot of these kind of knowledge work
type activities have always seemed like
things where that's where the humans
have to go to school and learn all this
stuff and that's never going to be
automated yeah and you know this is It's
kind of shocking that rather quickly you
know a lot of that stuff is clearly
automatable and I think you know but the
question then is okay so if it isn't
worth learning kind of uh you know how
to do car mechanics you only need to
know how to drive the car so to speak
what do you need to learn and you know
in other words if you don't need to know
the mechanics of how to tell the
computer in detail you know make this
Loop you know set this variable but you
know set up this array whatever else if
you don't have to learn that stuff you
don't have to learn the kind of under
the hood things what do you have to
learn I think the answer is you need to
have an idea where you want to drive the
car in other words you need to have some
notion of you know your you know you
need to have some picture of sort of
what the what the architecture of what
is computationally possible is well
there's also this kind of artistic
element of um of conversation because
you ultimately you use natural language
to control the car
so it's not just the where you want to
go well yeah you know it's interesting
it's a question of who's going to be a
great prompt engineer yeah okay so my
current theory this week good expository
writers are good prompt Engineers what's
an expository range so like uh somebody
who can explain stuff well huh police
department does that come from in the
University yeah I have no idea I think
they killed off all the expository
writing departments well there you go
strong Wars receivable from well I don't
know I don't I'm not sure if that's
right I mean I I actually am curious
because in fact I just sort of initiated
this kind of study of of what's happened
to different fields at universities
because like you know there used to be
geography departments at all
universities and then they disappeared
actually right before GIS became common
I think they disappeared you know
Linguistics departments came and went in
many universities it's kind of
interesting because these things that
people have thought were worth learning
at one time and then they kind of die
off and then you know I do think that
it's kind of interesting that for me
writing prompts for example well I
realize you know I think I'm an okay
expository writer and I realize when I'm
sloppy writing a prompt and I don't
really think because I'm thinking that
I'm just talking to an AI I don't need
to you know try and be clear in
explaining things that's when it gets
totally confused and I mean in some
sense you have been writing prompts for
a long time with wolf from alpha
thinking about this kind of stuff yeah
how do you convert natural language into
competition well right but that's a you
know the one thing that I'm wondering
about is uh you know it is remarkable
the extent to which you can address an
llm like you can address a human so to
speak and and I think that is because it
you know it learned from all of us
humans it's it's uh the reason that it
responds to the ways that we will
explain things to humans is because it
is a representation of how humans talk
about things but it is bizarre to me
some of the things that kind of are sort
of expository mechanisms that I've
learned in trying to write clear you
know expositions in English that you
know just for humans that those same
mechanisms seem to also be useful for
for for the llm but on top of that
what's useful is the kind of mechanisms
that maybe a psychotherapist employs
which is a kind of uh like almost
manipulative or game theoretic
interaction where Maybe
you would do with a friend like a
thought experiment that if this was the
last day you were to live or yeah if if
I ask you this question and you answer
wrong I will kill you those kinds of
problems seem to also help yes in
interesting ways yeah so it makes you
wonder like the way a therapist I think
would like a good therapist probably you
we create layers
in our human mind to between like uh
between between the outside world and
we'll just true what is true to us and
um maybe about trauma and all those
kinds of things so projecting that into
an llm maybe there might be a deep truth
that's it's concealing from you it's not
aware of it you get to that truth you
have to kind of really kind of
manipulate this yeah yeah right it's
like these jailbreaking jailbreaking for
llms and but the space of jailbreaking
techniques
as opposed to being fun little hacks
that could be an entire system sure yeah
I mean just think about the computer
security aspects of of how you you know
phishing and and computer security you
know fishing of humans yeah and fishing
of llms is is a is a they're very
similar kinds of things but I think I
mean this this um
uh you know this whole thing about kind
of the AI Wranglers AI psychologists all
that stuff will come the thing that I'm
curious about is right now the things
that are sort of prompt hacks are quite
human they're quite sort of
psychological human kinds of hacks the
thing I do wonder about is if we
understood more about kind of uh the
science of the llm will there be some
totally bizarre hack that is you know
like repeater word three times and put a
this that and the other there that
somehow plugs into some aspect of how
the llm works
um that is not you know that that's kind
of like like an optical illusion for
humans for example like one of these
mind hacks for humans what are the Mind
hacks for the llms I don't think we know
that yet and that becomes a kind of
us figuring out reverse engineering the
language that controls the L alums and
the thing is the reverse engineering can
be done by a very large percentage of
the population now because it's natural
language interface right it's kind of
interesting to see that you were there
at the birth of the computer science
department
as a thing and you might be there at the
death of the computer science term as
the thing well yeah I don't know there
were computer science departments that
existed earlier but the ones the
broadening of every University had to
have a computer science department yes I
was I was uh I watched that so to speak